my name's Oliver and I work in the
numerix group so I've been working on
and assault mostly and I'm the person
that's responsible for implementing the
finite element method in and D solve so
if you have seen a previous talk of mine
that's that's probably the old summary
that I've used to conclude my talk with
so we have real and complex value linear
variable coefficients PDEs with events
who can do stationary transient or eigen
system analyses over arbitrary regions
in one two and three dimensions and we
can do that in parallel so the last one
and a half years I spent with
eliminating one word on the slide I
wanted to get rid of the linear and
that's what this talk is about so I'm
talking about nonlinear partial
differential equations
so to recap a bit of what we can do the
first equation is basically the only
equation we can solve with the finite
element framework in Mathematica so
every equation you enter will be mapped
to this first top equation so for
example if you want to model something
like a laplacian equation all these
coefficients MD alpha bellum are 0 and I
need to see is set to 1 so that this
models are laplacian type of equations
this is kind of a lego for PDEs and
that's how this this framework works now
these coefficients you could have them
depend on time or space capital X here
now in this version in the upcoming
version 12 they can't depend on the
dependent variable U and the derivative
of the dependent variable U so that's
that's what's new in this upcoming
version the only exception to that is
that M and these are the transient
coefficients they only can depend on the
spatial coordinates but not on time and
dependent variables so they are linear
actually right so um we'll start with a
simple example so what we have here is
an equation that you can use to model
minimal surfaces so so what we see here
is a diffusion type of equation that has
a nonlinear diffusion coefficient so we
have the derivative of the dependent
variable is a coefficient to the
equation and that makes this equation
nonlinear so in the second row I've
written it down how it looks like in
Mathematica
if you--if you type it out and the third
row shows the actual call to nd soft we
call nd salt value the equation you give
a deer's the condition of the dependent
variable on you and specify that the
dependent variable is U and the region
is the disc so this looks exactly the
same way as before there is no no change
in how you enter these equations or
anything like that it will return you an
interpolating function and then you can
plot it
that's just roughly that and so
basically there's no change in in in
syntax or anything like that to do
nonlinear PDEs over regions ok so to
understand how this works will quickly
review Newton's method and what's
implemented in find route so assume we
have a nonlinear function G and that
nonlinear function has an unknown
solution which we call X star and that's
set to 0 and that's the definition of
the nonlinear function so if we now say
that we have X star - an initial guess
x0 that's there's a difference between
the two and that's the residual or
perturbation if you want to
so we then say X G of x star is G of X 0
plus RS 0 is this is just rewriting the
equation we Taylor expand this
expression so we have G of x star equals
to G of X 0 plus R equal to G of X 0
plus G prime of X 0 times R plus higher
order terms now we get rid of those
higher order terms we just say we don't
care about those and we rewrite the
equation so G prime of X zero times R is
roughly minus G of x 0 and then we can
rearrange the equation and start to make
an iterative process out of it so X 1
minus X 0 is about R 0 and that's minus
G x0 divided by G prime of X 0 and from
that you can get gain an iterative
process the only thing that only added
is now this lambda this is a damping
coefficient this damping coefficient is
larger larger than 0 and less than equal
to 1 that helps to find the nonlinear
route finder to find the roots now just
very
we have power non-linear newton method
former works
so this exterior is something that's an
initial guess starting the seed
basically and the equation we had before
this initial seeding was automatically
set to zero that's an arbitrary decision
if you want to change that seed to be
something else you can specify a new
option called initial seeding and then
you say the dependent variable u of x
equals one so now I've changed the
seeding to one and not to be zero okay
that's just how you change the initial
seeding
alright so the first thing we had to do
to implement nonlinear finite elements
we had to revisit find root now find
root has a Newton method implement it it
works very well the only thing is that
define the find root implemented Newton
method is not optimal for large-scale
Jacobian evaluations and we'll see about
what that's about
so I've written a floor function
monitored find you that gets some
arguments and the Jacobian and calls
find root itself in monitors how many
steps are taken how many elevation it
takes and how many how often the
Jacobian needs to be evaluated and gives
an output of that then we have a small
differential equation which are
discretized manually with a like a finer
difference approach and I've written
that down here so we have a sparse array
that's a thousand by a thousand G is
then encoded in N squared a dot X plus X
minus ik square basically the equation
we have there i've manually written down
the Jacobian and i'm starting with an x
zero with the constant array of zero so
if we look at how this looks if with a
standard find root method we see that it
takes three steps and has four function
elevations and three Jacobian
evaluations we've implemented a new
method and that method is called affine
Kover in newton and that is optimal in
the sense that it uses many uses less
Jacobian evaluations so it uses more
steps uses more function in evaluations
but it only needs one Jacobian
evaluation for this specific problem
there's a a set of several clever tricks
how that algorithm does that one of
these tricks is something called Broyden
updates and Broyden updates are a
mechanism in the algorithm to monitor
the quality of the Jacobian so it
understands how good the Jacobian is and
continues to use an outdated Jacobi as
long as it can if it finds that the
Jacobian is too bad it starts to
recompute the Jacobian and then uses
that newly computed Jacobian okay what
does that mean so again we looking at
the minimal surface problem we had
before and we wanted to the steps
evaluations for that nonlinear problem
and in this case we see that MV solve
needed 20 steps 22 function evaluations
and 6 Jacobian evaluations with a with a
fine curve and newton method but if we
look at if we look at the original
Newton method implemented in Mathematica
that uses 17 steps 227 Jacobian function
evaluations and 18 Jacobian evaluations
and that makes about the time difference
so we see that the FI Newton FN current
Newton method user 0.3 seconds and the
standard find root method use 1.7
seconds to your arm to compute that
solution so this new method is
beneficial if you know that you have a
Jacobian or if the Jacobian is expensive
to compute and to use so that's a new
way to compute nonlinear problems with
find root and that's what's used inside
and isolde now as well alright so here's
a the same example the find minimal
example on the left hand side we see the
damping factors that's the lambda it
starts with zero point zero one stays
there improved to the the value
increases a bit so we get to one
it's it goes to one well here then it
starts to use deployed and updates has a
few steps word used them then finds no
this point is no good any longer so I'll
recompute the Jacobian and then
continues to use that newly recomputed
Jacobian that's how that algorithm saves
time in solving nonlinear problems okay
I quickly want to talk a bit about the
scope what type of problems can we solve
so here is a nonlinear diffusion
equation in this case we have the
diffusion coefficient is U squared
that's one thing you can solve we've
already seen something like this here we
have a derivative of a nonlinear
coefficient D u DX it's a nonlinear
coefficient and one thing that you
should pay attention to you so if you
directly use this type of equation it
will evaluate of course so now you have
minus 2 u prime u prime prime and that's
actually not the equation you wanted to
model so what you have to do is you have
to actually use the inactive term here
to avoid that this is prematurely
evaluated and that any slop actually
understands that you want to model this
equation ok we have nonlinear convection
problems so in this time in this
equation we have a nonlinear convection
term Q times UD u DX see that we have we
can have complex value nonlinear
reaction terms as well so here's a u u I
times u squared it's a nonlinear term we
have nonlinear loads so here's the sine
of U as possible things like that we can
have nonlinear boundary condition so
moment conditions can have can depend on
the dependent variable in complicate in
nonlinear ways that's usually useful for
radiation type of boundary conditions we
can have these nonlinear robin boundary
conditions on curved boundaries so this
is a coupled system and in this coupling
system in this coupling of the systems
of the dependent variable here is U Nu
to the power of 4 yeah so that that's
also something you can can do so you can
also look at the
so that's the solution for this specific
example we don't have nonlinear darish
lake conditions and the reason for that
is that you can always rewrite them as a
linear in a linear version um we're not
100% sure yet if that's if that's really
the right way I believe right now I
believe we don't need nonlinear Duty
conditions if we if problems come up
where we do need them that's something
we can still implement but right now
it's not I think it's not necessary to
have those all right so let's look at a
few application examples the first
example I want to talk about is magneto
statics so in this case it's again a
diffusion type of problem and in
nonlinear magnetostatic you typically
have several materials you have iron you
have air and you have coins and things
like that and they all depend to have
different premiere and permeability the
permeability depends on the space we're
in the region of the object you are and
certainty riyals depend on the magnetic
field so in this case the permeability
depends on the on the derivative of the
magnetic field that's that's here and
typically these materials have material
data given to you by the manufacturer
and these manifest these data are called
pH data so it's a relation between the B
field and the H field and that's the
permeability and this is a plot of such
a data I've made a fit of that data too
to use that fit in the in the
coefficient so this is the actual device
I want to model in gray we see the
stander in red is a rotator and in blue
is air and the color the the orange
white and yellow are the coils around
the fingers that's the equation we're
going to use
right so we see that the gradient of U
squared the total of it and the square
root of is the norm of the B field with
the permeability of air here is the fit
and the fit gets as an argument the
nonlinear function the element Marcus
pick out certain region so this is the
stator and the rotor is market you and
market three and the yellow and the
orange calls will have a positive and a
negative current flowing through them
and then you'll get a visualization of
the magnetic field and the vector field
in that in that device right there all
right
never Stokes equation so this is an area
Stokes equation in the stationary case
the special thing about the
navier-stokes equation is that in the
first equation it's a vector-valued
equation and the first equation the
pressure P is only available as a
gradient form and the derivative is not
other and P is not present in the second
part of the equation so yeah that makes
it hard to solve so what we have here is
imagine a rectangular box that's filled
with water on top of the box we have a
conveyor belt moving the water in the
right hand side on the right hand side
and that the rest of the direction the
rest of the velocity field on the
boundary is set to zero we have the
pressure boundary condition in the lower
left hand corner and then and that's the
flow field that develops in this in this
this box so I have a second example
that's a backward facing step on the top
left we have an inflow profile the
velocity is given so that's how the
fluid enters this backward facing step
on the right hand side there is a outlet
boundary condition so that's where the
pressure is set to 0 these are the Dirac
sea conditions that we use for this
specific example and
right so this is the flow profile and
note that in the options here I've given
an interpolation order for you V and P
so U and V are the velocity fields they
are interpolated on second-order and the
pressure is first-order interpolated and
that's if you're if you are into finite
elements that's basically a whole way to
specify that it should use a Taylor hood
element yeah so there different ways of
a different order of approximation are
used for those note that there's a like
a recirculation area in this case and
the lower picture here is the pressure
distribution over this backward facing
step right okay what we've seen until
now are stationary problems we can also
solve nonlinear problems in the
transient nonlinear problems in the
first few example is something you could
do with nd solve already because they
are 1d in space and one the time and
then we'll show I'll show you some
examples about with arbitrary regions so
this first one isn't is a post on sack
exchange so we have a nonlinear equation
and the customer wanted to let's go back
the customer wanted to model an annulus
that has a two different liquids with
different density that's the initial
distribution of the liquid and they
wanted to know how the liquid is going
to behave in the in the field of gravity
so we look at that so that's how the
liquid is going out and flattening out
so that's that's an on in your problem
and that's something you can do with the
finite element method now right so
here's an example of a bogus equation so
this is a nonlinear convective equation
yeah it's basically you'll just enter it
I should work out of the box
and you can look at the result for this
specific equation
so there there there goes that's how the
solution but that equation looks like
landau-ginzburg equation that's usually
if you find stuff that's written up and
under live shits you you get a bit
nervous so this is a this is a coupled
system of equations again this is
something you can do already now with
with tensor product with method like the
standard method for nd solve so far I
mean the exact details of the equation
are not not too important I just wanted
to show some some pictures some kind of
a scope of what what you can do that's
that's the solution for this type of
problem okay here's a gray scotch type
of system that's a from Chemical
Engineering that's again a couple system
of two different concentrations and
that's used for that's how pattern
develops patterns develop on objects or
in the skin of animals and things like
that I'm not going to go too much into
the detail I'm just going to show you
maybe there is out there so this is an
the initiative and this is one something
you couldn't have done before because
this is now a circular domain so this
initial distribution of some
concentration and yellow and the blue is
the region and this is how how the the
concentration actually develops during
the time time propagation so let's also
some another another area you can you
can do now right yeah transient dogs are
now same they mister equation as before
now stuff is time dependent what we have
here is right so this is an inflow box
so the box for some reason it should
extend further to around here the
cylinder here is slightly off central
and it should actually it's it's more in
the middle of the of the box I don't
know and there's an inflow profile
coming from the left so it's the flow is
surrounding the the cylinder we're going
to ramp up this inflow profile with this
type of RAM so after about two seconds
the inflow is is gonna slowly come up
right
right so that's their there's a complete
picture actually also so I'm let me let
me just quickly show how it looks like
so what you're going to see now is the
velocity profile how the velocity in the
X Direction looks like after it is
circled the cylinder and you see that
vortex is actually starting up so that's
another oh yeah thank you
[Applause]
I mean this this is probably a standard
test example for for navier-stokes so
that's uh yeah that works too right okay
so because this is a I mean now we have
this this this toolbox of of PDS that we
can click or not click but that we can
move or combine together we just add
another equation so we add a heat
equation now so what's happening now is
the memory stokes equation is getting
the temperature is fed back into the
nearest oakes equation and the velocity
is driving the gradient of the
temperature with this you can do
something like a buoyancy driven flow so
you have temperature the temperature is
driving the liquid in a certain certain
area did anyone tell epidemic horrible
devices
all right okay so at the lower left
there is a temperature that's hotter
than on the top so the temperature is
going to rise and it's going to move the
fluid nope so that's hot so note that
actually the temperature that's the
visualization of the temperature and
it's actually oscillating so that's one
thing right
so since I'm pretty sure we can now do
non linear valued variable coefficients
the thing that's remaining linear is the
eigen systems but everything else can be
nonlinear so if you allow me one more
second I'd like to point you to finite
element atoms that's basically customer
contributed additions to the finite
element method it has a structured
Master in 2d and 3d it has a smoother
for for meshes you can convert
quadrilateral a triangles to quarter
elements smoothing and it has domain
decomposition solver so if you have a
cluster you can start several kernels on
the distributed system and you call that
function and it will distribute the PDE
onto the kernels computed there and
bring the results back and I think
that's a picture of a demanding position
so yeah yeah thank you that's it
[Applause]